I was auditioning for two roles in Les  Mis I had more of a look of cozette but  I had the range vocally of eponine so we  really want to like make you look like  eponine we're going to try to do it's  the you know if she wasn't like loaded  she had Brown teeth you know like she  didn't have a lot of money so they were  like we're actually gonna paint your  teeth Brown for this and I'm like so  you're gonna do that after I meet Eddie  Redman right that's that's not something  you do before this is just everybody's  gonna meet you with the brown teeth  we're gonna like do like big circles  under your eyes like you're near death  and I was like this this has immediately  become a nightmare for me you were so  nice I think when I met you I was like